All right. Hadar Pode, thank you so much for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
Hey, thank you for having me.
It's so great to have you here. You're calling from Tel Aviv right now?
No, I actually am calling from Kiryat Ono where I live now. But previously I lived for many years in Tel Aviv.
And prior to that in Jerusalem and prior to that in New York. I was actually born in New York.
Amazing. Hadar, you have a very unique job which I think most entrepreneurs and most people
around me aren't even aware that it exists, especially in the industry that you're in.
What is the title that you hold within Porsche?
So, I work at a subsidiary Porsche called Porsche Digital and I'm a director there
and leading the activities, the innovation activities and scouting in Israel.
So leading the innovation and scouting activities in Israel for one of the most successful automobiles companies
in the world, a subsidiary of it that is intended for ventures, for innovation and creation.
Why does a car manufacturing company, luxury car company need an arm of innovation and ventures?
So, I am sure that all of your viewers are aware that Israel is not a startup nation but now is
becoming a scale up nation and a lot of the technologies that are super relevant
not only for an organization as an organization but also as a mobility player or a tech giant
are coming from Israel. So, a lot of of machine learning --
What is difference between a scale up nation and a startup nation by the way?
So, you're not familiar?
I need to know.
Okay so, there's a shift in the mindset of now leaders, and investors, and entrepreneurs in Israel
trying to not just promote Israeli founders to start companies and sell them relatively quickly
but rather to expand them and not just sell them as fast as they can
but to build big big successful companies.
So I am personally very in favor of this shift. A paradigm shift.
And I hope that we'll see more and more companies scaling in Israel and not selling too fast our companies.
So, just for context, for every one who doesn’t understand, so we had this startup nation,
this wonderful, miraculous idea of Israel. This tiny hub of creativity and innovation by force.
People are forced to be innovative and creative from a very young age
generally attributed to the army.
And then we received some critics, some criticism as the exit nation
because we developed the amazing technologies and sell them short instead of trying to grow them
But recently we've seen some incredible innovators like Fiverr, Lemonade, Wix, Mobily, and so many more.
A ... that are now unicorns, ways of course, and so scale up nation.
Okay. Now, back to Porsche.
Yup, so we opened our facility officially in 2018.
Prior to that, our leadership basically it came and was started to develop a very big interest
toward the Israeli market and the innovation coming from here.
And one thing led to another and they eventually decided that they need permanent people here.
An official office. And somebody that would pursue owning this activity.
I was lucky enough and privileged enough to be introduced to Porsche via Grove
which is a prominent VC in Israel.
Grove? Yeah, so
Porsche invested in Grove prior to me and my colleague--
Oh really. Okay, I didn’t know that.
Yeah. And they were looking for a person in Israel and we were connected.
I was quite hesitant while Porsche is reaching out to me.
I had actually an interview at my former office at Deloitte.
Basically met with them. Didn't know what they want but was truly excited about their idea of
developing something in Israel and seeking Israeli innovation
And with the hopes of deploying it.
So yeah, something led to another. I joined in late 2018.
Basically, our office has two core activities.
One is Tech Scouting, not just for the sake of doing project or POCs but for the sake of deployment.
So, the range of--
What does that mean, deployment? When you think of deployment, what does that mean?
Does it actually mean integrating technology within the cars themselves?
Definitely. So, this is one. But also, on the enterprise level or production.
We seek to see technologies being integrated into our facilities.
Into our computers. Into everything.
So we worked together with our colleagues at Porsche AG, the parent company.
In ... where the R&D Center in Stuttgart
And we basically try to analyze potential companies.
We have basically a dual methodology of scouting, both a pull and a push.
So, the most preferred way is to get companies to get a specific request from a business unit
To really understand the specific need.
And then to go and analyze the most relevant companies and to bring them to the table
and potentially do a POC, and once the POC is--
So this is like a top-down approach where you have a business unit within Porsche
that says, "Hey, we have this problem. Can we do some scouting?"
And see if there's any interesting early, middle, or late stage startups, perhaps in Israel
that are working in the space and then we can approach them proactively
and try to get some sort of collaboration. That's the way that you are referring to?
Yeah. So, this is the primary way where we see a very high conversion rate.
Because inherently we will have a business unit. We will have a project lead, a budget and everything.
But definitely we are extremely proactive in trying to advocate new companies,
or a new business models that are particularly interesting for a specific unit.
And sometimes the unit cannot really articulate themselves.
Okay, we acknowledge this technology. Sometimes are not.
They will not be aware of what is exactly is in the market.
And this is why we also focus on meeting constantly with companies, and with VCs,
and with major stakeholders and trying to be ahead of the game, basically.
So, this is one arm we have conducted in 2019 over 10 POCs
We deployed several technologies. 2020 had a rough start with covid
But we were thankful enough to - just a little - to conduct various POCs and deployment
Yeah, so we're working hard. It's a small team but we're trying to do a lot.
And that is the whole investment side, right? Where you're actually a venture arm
that is making active investments in companies.
So, basically Porsche ventures is the CVC, the strategic investor arm of Porsche.
We invest in four different locations around the globe, in the US, Germany, China, and Israel.
My colleague Talia is more focusing on the investment side, I'm on the tech scouting.
But obviously we do everything together.
On to what? Sorry. You're focus on what?
I'm doing the tech scouting. Tech scouting. Okay
Yeah, yeah. Innovation and doing all of the project.
But it goes hand in hand. Because every investment,
we can't do an investment prior to validation of the technology. So, we will start with the POC
and then see that we're fascinated about the technology and we see a very disruptive approach
and then we will potentially proceed to analyzing a potential investment.
And you will only invest then in companies that are specifically relevant to your domain,
your expertise, and technologies that you can validate as Porsche, right?
So, definitely we are always looking how to push the boundaries
and do new types of mobility, and do things that are not just within the car
but definitely we have our core activity, but there are new topics and new things that we're looking at.
So constantly looking and trying to innovate also within the topics that are relevant for us.
Okay. So, talk to me a little bit about how you got into this.
It's not that ordinary to meet somebody who is working on the venture
and innovation arm of a car manufacturing company, a leading one especially at that, Porsche.
So, it's a very very cool job. But I loved to know who holds that job.
So, Deloitte ITT, a Lawyer for many years, who are you?
It's a tough question. I don't know. I'm not only my job roles, but I think I'm a person
who has a lot of other passions and interests. But I don't know.
Where do you wanted me to start from?
I wanna start from the passions. What are you actually passionate about?
You have a lot of background in the tech space now.
From a lot of different point, angles coming in to it.
What are you really really excited about?
Basically pushing innovation and trying to help big companies succeed through
collaboration with startups. So, obviously I'm a big passionate ambassador of the Israeli startup nation
And trying to support Israeli companies and founders.
But also want to try to help big corporations understand and acknowledge
that they can't solve everything internally. They need to utilize external technologies
to solve big problem and to make a big impact
So, yup. Passionate about impact and helping others.
That one ... the ITT, was the ITT sort of being an ambassador
and representative of the startup nation?
So, it's a good question. So, it's my time it was called Deloitte Innovation Tech Terminal
And now it is rebranded as Deloitte Catalyst.
So, me and my former colleague Amit Harel basically joined forces
to establish this new startup activity of Deloitte US and Israel
With the main aspiration of helping Deloitte's largest clients to tap in
to the Israeli ecosystem and try to find not only the best companies
but the right way to solve business issues through investments, acquisitions, and deployments.
And we've done quite similarly to what I do now
activities with Deloitte's largest clients
And we hosted C suite of fortune 100.
And we were divided, our team was divided into sectors.
So people, one guy was the domain manager in terms of mobility, and fintech, and retail, and healthcare
And we have a lot of very talented team members that were focusing on each domain
And we basically helped really big clients understand how they can utilize exactly
the Israeli tech to solve their biggest issues
And through I think the two and a half years of my tenure there,
we were privileged to execute more than 80 global projects
We I think helped multinationals realize that they’re not only interested in deploying a certain technology
or potentially investing in a company but rather opening an R&D Center,
or an innovation hub in Israel.
So companies like TD Bank and others were good examples. And yeah, it was a great great time.
And it helped me to realize how fascinating this job could be
At the time I was a service provider essentially, so I was not making calling the shots, right?
But I was helping. I was trying, our team was trying to support these decision makers in taking big changes.
In shifting mindsets and helping them solve their biggest issues through Israeli technologies.
I love it. I love it. And Hadar, so talk to me a little bit about this.
Some of the struggles of a large corporation to go and integrate you know POCs and software
from early or middle stage start ups. So, one of things you mentioned
that you're very excited about is helping large enterprises realize the potential
of the outside ecosystem and sort of amending some of the things that the company wants or need. Right?
So, instead of developing internally, going to say, "Okay, is there maybe a startup that can help us do that
and make that connection?" What are some of the difficulties, or some of the opportunities
that you're seeing within that realm?
So, the difficulties I think are quite obvious. So, organizations work much much much slower.
In comparison to startups that everyday it's a rollercoaster.
So, in one month you can pivot twice, you can raise a lot of funds.
you can expand the team or decrease the amount of the team, the FTEs by by I don’t know what.
And basically startups can’t really afford to have two months of execution of an NDA
prior to even seriously discussing a potential collaboration, right?
So, I think one of the big issue is to-- or not issue
but one of our rules is to try to expedite processes.
To try to help an organization understand that they need to be a bit more agile in their mindset.
How does that happen actually though? Do you actually go, so do you go to the senior vice president and say,
"Listen, you're now dealing with the startup. It's not another business,
Like get moving". How do you actually expedite the process for this?
Yeah. So, it’s quite delicate ‘cause we can’t be super super duper Israeli.
We can’t push in after a meeting maybe 10 emails because they would not be very appreciative of that.
But we definitely try to do it to get things done as fast as we can.
To be very I don't know supportive and respective of the time of a company
that startup cannot afford too much time. And this is one major issue.
A lot of other things are cultural differences.
You know sometimes, Israelis are very upfront and there are other things that
not every organization are, type of people as confrontational as Israelis.
And there are a lot of other differences that we try to mitigate or try to bridge.
There are bunch of other topics. I don't know.
I'm sure. You know I think is is fascinating just you know, considering this.
And I think what’s really fascinating is that where we're headed, and I'm saying this constantly here,
this idea that the world is changing so so fast.
A lot of these businesses, you know, you can look at covid coming in
And a great example is, one of my best friends has a startup in Tel Aviv
Covid hit and he's in the travel space. Covid hit, basically crushed his business
had to forego a third to a half of his employees,
and he was able to pivit within 24 hours and go to a whole new route.
And he actually built something that over a quarter of million of people use right now to help decide where to travel.
On the same note, you have larger companies,
Is it Miki, your friend? Yeah, Miki. Okay. There you go.
Yeah, he's in Israel. We know everybody.
Hi Miki. So, on the other hand you have large corporations which are getting covid
And now they have to decide. How long do we wait until we make that pivot?
How much are we considering this, how much pivoting can we do once we've already settled down
And we have this core business opportunity. And if we wanna pivot,
can we do it fast enough internally or do we wanna utilize a startup outside to do that?
So I think it's all really fascinating questions because I think covid was just an example
of circumstances that are gonna cause huge consumer shifts and market shifts
and we're just getting the knock on the head of,
"Okay, maybe we have to be a little bit more agile as a world than we were before."
But alright, I can't believe 20 minutes are almost up. It always saddens me.
Seriously. Okay, here we go.
I have to ask you the most important question.
I need three words that you would best describe yourself
or that any of your colleagues, or any of the startups that you have invested in
they would describe Hadar.
So it’s hard because I don’t like talking too much about myself
and I like to give, I don't know.
And just for the record, I'm forcing you to say this. This is not your choice.
Yeah, yeah. Okay. Okay, I'll do it.
I think the first word would be doer
so I try to get it done. I'm very pragmatic and trying to push stuff forward
Second thing I think it correlates to what I said before.
So I'm very passionate whether it's with respect to my work, to Israel, to innovation, to helping people.
Stuff like that. Maybe Hillel could say some words about that.
And the third word would be connector
So through my job and also just my time of, I'd like to not only connect internally with people
but connect with other people and just connection and then people.
Something that I do on a daily basis.
I love it. Hadar, toda raba. Thank very very much.
... You're awesome.
And I look forward to meeting you in Israel after this whole corona thing is over.
Yeah. Definitely yeah. Wonderful.
Okay, bye. Thank you so much.